The year was 1720, and the South Sea Company had become the grandest illusion of them all.
Even Sir Isaac Newton, he who had bent the heavens to his will, who had measured the orbits
of planets with the precision of a clockmaker, had been undone by it. He lost a fortune. Not
because he lacked intelligence, but because he failed to see the truth. The market was never
about numbers. It was about the fever, the dopamine rush of watching numbers dance, the way
a man could stare at a ticker tape and mistake it for his own heartbeat. This is the art
of market mastery in reverse. You see, the market isn't a place to win. It's a place
to participate, to twist yourself into knots of anxiety, to let every fluctuation become
a personal betrayal. The goal isn't profit. It's involvement, the kind that leaves you
breathless, that makes your stomach clench at the sound of a news alert, that turns your
portfolio into a mirror of your own unraveling. Let's begin with the ticker.
Ah, the ticker. That relentless clacking machine, spitting out numbers like a doctor's stethoscope
listening to the chest of a dying patient. In numerical obsession, we called it a heart
monitor and it is. But not for your body. For your soul. To master it, you must train yourself
to crave the check. Not the return. The check. The little jolt of adrenaline when you pull
up your account, when you see the numbers flicker, when you feel that familiar twist in your gut.
This is hyperbolic discounting and action trading the slow, steady comfort of ignorance for the
sharp, fleeting thrill of knowing. Even if knowing only confirms your ruin. You become a maximizer of
data, a satisfacer of nothing. Now, the instructions for despair are simple. Follow them closely.
First, there's a high-water mark trap. You must anchor your worth to the highest point your portfolio
ever reached. Not your current balance. Not your realistic expectations. The peak. Because when the
market inevitably stumbles, when it regresses to the mean, as it always does, you'll feel it like a
theft. Not a correction. A theft. Your brain will rewrite the numbers, not as fluctuations, but as
personal slights. The market didn't just drop. It chose to drop. It wanted to drop. And it did so
because of you. Then, there's the buying high protocol. You'll use social media as your oracle.
Every time an asset becomes the darling of Twitter, of LinkedIn, of whatever platform's latest mirage,
you'll buy. Not because it's undervalued. Not because it's undervalued. Not because it's a bargain.
Because it's at its peak end. Because the moment everyone is talking about it is the moment it will
begin to fall. And when it does, you'll have already sunk your money into the wreckage. You'll have
turned your own enthusiasm into a gravestone. And selling? Oh, selling is where the real artistry
lies. When the market dips, you must interpret it as a systemic structure of conspiracy designed to
punish you specifically, not the economy. Not the algorithm. You. So you'll panic. You'll sell at the
bottom. You'll lock in your losses with the same certainty a gambler places his last chip on red.
Because what's the alternative? Holding? No. Holding is for people who believe in patience. You believe
in suffering. You want the loss to be real. You want the regret to be tangible. You want to stand in the
wreckage of your own decisions and whisper, I did this. Finally, there's the recursive audit.
You'll surround yourself with noise. Financial news, pundits, experts who contradict each other
with the enthusiasm of preachers at a revival. You'll let the cacophony fill your head until your
brain is nothing but static. No clarity. No calm. Just the hum of a thousand voices all telling you the
same thing. You are not in control. And you'll love it. Because in that chaos, you'll feel alive.
You'll feel involved. You'll feel like the market isn't just a force outside of you. It's a part of
you. Your blood pressure will rise and fall with the Fed's decisions. Your sleep will be haunted by the
3 a.m. portfolio check. Your nights will be spent staring at numbers, waiting for the next drop. The
next confirmation that you are, in fact, losing yourself. This is the human ticker. You are no
longer an investor. You are a living, breathing extension of the market's volatility. Your worth
is measured in ticks. Your anxiety is currency. And the ultimate irony? The more you participate,
the more you lose. Not just money, but the ability to ever feel stable again. The market can stay
irrational longer than you can stay solvent. And you? You can stay miserable longer than the market can
stay irrational. That's the deal. Now go check your portfolio again.